[Musique]
pour moi c'est l'indépendance la
persévérance un défi c'est l'engagement
la volonté de réussir par soi-même je
dirais la confiance
[Musique]
entrepreneuriat pour tous c'est un
nouveau concept que nous avons lancé
l'année dernière pour permettre aux
personnes qui sont un peu plus éloignées
de l'emploi de créer leur propre
entreprise
de 250 heures de formation sur trois
mois qui sont complètement gratuites et
offertes par l'agglomération de 50 ans
en Yvelines la première promotion on
avait eu 14 personnes en formation sur
ces 14 personnes 8 ont créé leur
entreprise
[Musique]
je suis animatrice sociale et j'ai
décidé de créer une société qui
s'appelle Atoum amine qui a pour but de
proposer de l'animation auprès de
personnes âgées et en situation de
handicap pour pouvoir rompre l'isolement
je vais développer des activités de
coaching et de formation dans le domaine
des biotechnologies puisque c'est là
d'où je viens depuis 25 ans de carrière
et par contre en terme de d'activités
spécifiques ça va être d'amener de
l'humanité dans le management je suis
esthéticienne de formation et je compte
ouvrir une un beauty bar un bar à beauté
on va proposer des prestations de beauté
au niveau de l'onglerie vernis semi
permanent pose de faux-ongles il y aura
un espace également dédié à l'épilation
et il y aura également un espace dédié
aux prestations autour du regard
[Musique]